- [Instructor] The goal of
this video is to feel good
about the connection
that we've talked about
between the absolute
value of the determinant
of a two by two matrix
and the area of the
parallelogram that's defined
by the two column vectors of that matrix.
So for example, I have this column vector
right over here ac, so
that's this blue vector.
So this distance right over here,
it goes a in the x direction.
So this distance right over here is a,
and then it goes c in the y direction.
So this distance right
over here is equal to c.
And so this distance up
here is also equal to a,
and this is also equal to c.
So we have this vector
and then we have the bd vector,
and bd vector, so in the x direction
it goes a distance of b right over there.
Or if we draw it over here,
it goes a distance of b.
And in the vertical direction,
again it goes a distance of d.
So this right over here is d
and this distance right over here is d.
And we can see that the
parallelogram created or defined
by those two vectors, it's
area is right over there.
Now let's see if we can
connect that to the determinant
or the absolute value of the
determinant of this matrix.
And we're just going to assume
for the sake of simplicity
that a, b, c and d are positive values,
although we can in the
future do this same thing
where we had some other combination
where some of them are not positive,
but this will hopefully give you a clue
of how we can prove it.
Now, how can we figure out the
area of this parallelogram?
Well, one technique would be find the area
of this larger rectangle right over here,
and then from that,
subtract out the parts that
are not in the parallelogram.
And so let's do that.
So what's the area of
this larger rectangle?
Let's see the dimensions here are,
this length from here to here is a,
and then from here to here is b.
So this is a plus b on this side.
And on this side up here,
this part is d and then this
part is c right over here.
So it's d plus c.
So the area of the whole thing
is going to be a plus b, times d plus c,
which is equal to, we just do
the distributive property a few times.
It's going to be ad
plus ac plus bd plus bc.
Now, from that we're going
to wanna subtract out all
of these other parts that
are not in the parallelogram.
So let's do that.
So you have this triangle right over here
whose area would be ac over
two, a times c over two,
but you also have this one,
which has the same area.
So if we subtract both of them out
we'd wanna subtract out a total of ac.
Each of those are ac over two.
So to count both of them
let's subtract out an ac.
And then of course we could
do these two triangles.
And the area of each of these
triangles is bd over two,
b times d over two,
but add them together,
their combined area is bd.
So let's subtract that out, minus bd.
And now, what is the area
of this right over here?
Well, that is b times
c, so minus b times c,
actually and that's also the
area of this right over here.
So we have another b times c,
so minus 2bc.
So let's see what's going on.
So if we subtract these
out, that takes out that,
that takes out that, and
if you take bc minus 2bc
we're gonna be left
with just a negative bc.
So all of this is going to be equal
to ad, what we have there.
Bc minus 2bc is just
gonna be a negativebc.
Well, this is going to be the determinant
of our matrix, a times d minus b times c.
So this isn't a proof that
for any a, b, c, or d,
the absolute value of
the determinant is equal
to this area, but it
shows you the case where
you have a positive determinant
and all of these values are positive.
So hopefully that feels
somewhat satisfying.
And you can try, if you
like to prove the cases
if you don't have a positive determinant
or if some combination
of these are negative.